how's it going guys my name is DOM and
today I want to talk about classes in
JavaScript so basically for those of you
who haven't ever used classes before a
class is used to create one or more
objects so you can think of an object as
being a creation from a class definition
so these classes aren't actually used
directly by your program logic but they
used to create objects now these objects
are the ones that are actually used by
your program to achieve different things
so with that being said you can define
two main areas with a class definition
you can define what an object will have
so this is called an instance property
and also what they do this is called an
instance method so with instance
properties taking into basically example
of a human being a human might have a
name an age and a height so an instance
property describes the current state of
that object what they have is basically
just data about that property sorry that
objects so these instance properties are
unique to every object which is created
from that class definition so we now
have the instance methods this is what
they do so an instance method for human
being might be to talk to run and to
jump so this refers to what they
actually do what actions and their
behavior so typically an instance method
will use the instance properties to
achieve their result so if those two
main areas right there
so let's now create a class in Java
Script so down here
we can create a class definition by
using the class keyword let's talk about
class like that followed by the name of
your class let's create a class for a
rectangle let's type out a rectangle
right there now typically by convention
you want to use a capital letter at the
beginning of your class name so it's
going to be a rectangle with a capital R
just like that followed by two curly
braces so now inside here this is your
class definition so every class also has
what's called a constructor now the
constructor is basically just a method
which is ran only once during the life
of the objects so this constructor is
ran once and it's ran when the object is
being created so let's define this
constructor by typing a constructor like
that followed by two parentheses and
your normal curly braces so the
constructor is used to set up your
object okay so this behaves like a
normal method or normal function which
means if I type be a console.log inside
here and then just say the rectangle is
being created okay so now this method
constructor is ran when the object is
being created so we have a class let's
now create an object from that class so
down here let's create a new variable
and we'll call this one something like
my rectangle number one which is then
equal to a new object based off this
class let's type a new that's the that's
the new keyword and then say rectangle
just like that
and then to parentheses to actually call
that constructor method so if I was to
hover over this we see we get
constructor just like that so this will
call the constructor method so now if I
was to save this HTML file and then
refresh the web browser in the console
window we get the rectangle is being
created if I was to make two of these
rectangles so my rectangle number two
down here save this and refresh the
browser one more time
we get two messages of creation okay so
that is how the constructor method
actually works
okay the constructor is used to actually
up cell as it used to set up the actual
object so back to these instance
properties what you might commonly see
is the instance properties being defined
inside the constructor so we have a
rectangle now a rectangle might have a
width a height and also a color so let's
define these three instance properties
within the constructor so below here
best to find a instance property we can
do this by typing out this dot and then
the actual property name for example
week is equal to and then the value
let's just say it'll be five for now and
we can do the same thing for the other
two properties so save this and then dot
height equal to let's just say something
like um three and the color let's make
this a blue rectangle so the this
keyword right there that is a keyword
which refers to the current object so
when I say this I'm talking about the
objects which is being created by that
class
okay so we now have our three instance
properties defined inside the
constructor so now if I was to save this
and refresh the browser and in the
console if I just refer to the my
rectangle object or the variable here
okay
and press enter we can see we get three
properties those color height and width
which describe the current rectangle
okay so these properties are unique to
this rectangle instance alright so in
most cases though you actually define
instance properties when you construct
the object but these are typically
user-defined so usually you would type
in my rectangle and then say something
like three and then five and also maybe
the color so we'll say blue like that
okay pop this out blue so you want to
make this three five and blue actually
turn out to be the instance properties
for this created object
okay this allows you to make custom
rectangles with whatever values that you
actually pass in so to achieve this
result you actually want to make the
constructor function accept parameters
for arguments so let's type an
underscore here and then say height
actually this total bit so say we'd and
then cut and in colour so these are now
three parameters which are passed in
through the constructor function and
then these will be assigned to the
instance properties of this particular
rectangle object
so let's swap out this width with these
actual
variables right here so now we're
assigning the width of this fact I'm
going to be with height and color and so
on okay let's just make this a 5 and a 3
so now running this line of code right
here creates a rectangle with the with a
width of 5 a height of 3 and a color of
blue so these are all passed in and
inserted right there so now if I was to
save this one and refresh the browser we
get the same result let's just log out
the actual rectangle object we get this
rectangle with the five part of three
and a color of blue so with this
scenario we can actually create two
objects here two rectangles once again
for the second time
let's give different data let's say ten
five and then red so now using this
class definition but defining the
structure of this rectangle but giving
it custom values based on the individual
needs of this I guess current stay in
the program so first you save this and
refresh the browser this time
what other rectangle number one we get
width five three in blue number two we
get ten five and red so we can see how
the instance properties are unique to
the actual object being created we have
two squares here with different instance
properties for their data so that is the
actual instance properties and the
constructor function okay now for the
instance methods we can define these
under the constructor so to work out I
believe the area of a rectangle we
multiplied the width and the height so
we can actually create a method which
will give us the area of this rectangle
or the rep sample being created so let's
define a new instance method we can do
this by typing out the name of the
method let's say get area so you get
area right there that is the name of our
instance method followed by the two
parentheses right there and then the
brackets so inside here let's actually
just return the width and the height of
this rectangle so let's say return
return this dot bleep multiplied by this
height okay so now we should get
different return values from this method
based on the UM the rectangle being used
so for example down here let's say
console dot log and then let's say
rectangle one dot gets area okay so
using dot get area this will call the
instance method so for this rectangle
right here we should get five times
three for the second one rectangle
number to get area will give us ten
times five let's save this and refresh
the browser we get 15 and 50 okay so you
can see how these methods are defined in
the actual class definition and they're
generic
to the actual class and then they're
using the instance properties that are
defined by the constructor to give you
different results based on the object
being used okay now one more example of
the actual method let's make a method
that will actually print out a
description of the actual object
let's say print description okay
inside here let's just say console.log
and then just say something like I am a
rectangle and then this put the the
width and height will say this width and
then this height then we'll say and I am
and then there and in the actual color
that is color so now by calling this
printed description method on a
rectangle we get I'm a rectangle of
width times height and I am than the
color so now down here let's call the
print description method on the my
rectangle number two okay dot print
description house to save and refresh
this one we get the expected result
rectangle of ten times five and I am RIT
okay so just to recap we have a class
which is a definition basically a
structure of the eventual object being
created we have an instance property
which refers to data that is relevant to
each individual object being created and
we also have an instance method which
uses the instance properties to achieve
an action or some sort of result based
on once again each individual object
being created from that class ah
and that is the basics of classes in
JavaScript
I want to talk about getters and setters
in JavaScript classes
so basically getters and setters are
used to define methods on a class which
are then used as if their properties so
essentially they look like properties
but there are actually methods of that
plus so let's see with an example I'm
just going to define a class here in a
JavaScript and we'll call this one a
square okay
for the constructor let's just taking a
single argument here called width and
that'll be the width and the height of
the actual square so inside here let's
just say this dot which is equal to that
with the parameter and the same thing
for the height okay so now the square
has a equal width and height okay now we
have this basic square so to work out
the area of this square it'll be the
heart multiplied by the width okay so we
can actually define a getter to achieve
this so down here let's create a getter
for the area we can do this by typing
you get just like that then a space and
then specify the name of your getup and
this will be the actual name that you
type out as if it's a property so let's
just say get and then put down area
followed by parentheses okay then the
normal brackets there for the actual
method body so now inside here this is
now basically a function we can put any
logically white inside here we can do
anything so let's just return return
this street multiplied by this height
and that will give us the area of this
square so you can see how I put a return
statement inside this block because it
literally behaves as if it's a method
okay so now we can we can test this
getter we can create an instance of this
square so
just go down here and say we'll say
let's make a new variable and say I'll
call this one square one equal to a new
square with a width and height of
something like 25 okay so now down here
that's just console.log and then we're
gonna call this area get up by topping
out square one and then dots area so you
can see how it essentially behaves like
property okay
so there's no need to put any any
parentheses here because yeah it
literally is a property right now if I
was to save this one and then refresh
the browser okay we get 625 as a result
so 25 times 25 would be 625 let's make
that maybe for just something get a
small number so square off for width and
height save and refresh and we get 16 so
you can see how we're calling this area
get up running this this function body
but it behaves like it's a property I
guess that's the actual get our right
there so now let's actually create a
setter so a setter behaves basically in
the same way you can assign new values
to your instance properties with a
property like syntax so you can actually
do this you can say square one dot area
equals and then something like 25 for
example so let's create this set up so
this right here this line right there
will actually convert this 25 into a
width and height for these two
properties okay so back inside here
let's just create a for area so we'll
say set and then put area like that now
this one is gonna take a single argument
and that'll be this value right there so
let's say set area in parentheses that's
down area okay so now inside here we can
now simply just find these square roots
of this 25 and then we can assign that
that result to the width and height of
the script because obviously the square
root of the area would be the width and
height of the actual square so let's say
this is equal to the square root so we
use the math dot s qrt method and
passing here the area okay so now if I
was to pass in 25 inside here we'd say
the width is equal to the math dot
square root of 25 which is actually
going to be 5 okay so the width is to
the square root we can do the same thing
for the height so this is equal to and
we could just say this dot width for I
guess the consistency okay so now we can
run this code and that one right there
will change the value of the width and
height for this for this square so let's
just see how this thing looks so let's
get rid of that right there and console
dot log down here Square 1 dot area okay
let's save this and refresh the browser
okay 25 yeah of course that's actually
just consult log the width of this
square and also the HUD okay let's try
again save and refresh and they get
fired right there so we have converted
the initial width and height of 4 into 5
using this set up which modified the
width and the height based on the area
that you pass in that is the basics
right there others first
another example of how you can basically
treat these like a function so with this
getter let's actually keep track of how
many times we have requested this square
to give us the area so every time I call
this get up I want to actually increment
number which tells us how many times
we've called this gutter so up inside
here let's create a new instance room
and we'll call this one number number of
requests for area okay equal to zero so
when it's constructed we have no
requests for the area inside they get up
let's just say this done of requests for
area plus plus so now every time we
request for the area this will be
incremented so down here let's just get
rid of this um that right there and then
let's just say consult mod square one
dot area okay and do it let's just say
four times okay
so now if I was to then consult log and
say square one the number of requests
for area this should now equal for the
course of requested at four times and
that has been incremented four times
okay so now first you've saved this and
refresh the browser one last time you
can see we get the area and also number
four and that is how many times I've
actually requested for the area okay so
that is how you can use getters and
setters on classes in JavaScript
I want to talk about static methods in
JavaScript classes so basically a static
method is a method which you define on a
class but it is not actually part of the
instantiated object for what's being
created so basically a static method
does not require an instance of the
class to be created in order to be used
so a lot of static methods are what's
called a helper method so they're like
little utilities that are relevant to
that class but not really you know that
don't have a an object bound to them so
let's just see with an example
[Music]
I'm gonna define a new class here and
we'll go with the standard square
example so a class of of square and for
the constructor let's just take in a
width and the width will be assigned as
per usual to the sort of width and
height instance properties let's just
say constructor and we'll say this stuff
is equal to that width parameter and
this is also equal to width parameter so
now we have a square class with a
constructor so now let's just create an
instance of this square so down here
let's create a new variable here and
call this one square one equal to a new
square passing in a width of let's just
say X ok so now we have this this square
so if I also just contour dot log B
Square and console save this and refresh
the browser in the console we get
obviously a square with the date and
heart of eight so now let's create a
static method on this square class
that's basically gonna compare two
square instances and then let us know if
they are equal with the night so
in here let's define a static method we
can do this by first typing out the
keyword static followed by the name of
the method so let's just say maybe
equals equals okay sum up that write
equals and then this method here will
take in two parameters or two arguments
now the first one being obviously a
square and the second one being another
sweet let's just say a and B so a and B
are two different square instances all
right and the equals static method is
going to check the width and height of
these two squares and then give us the
result if they are equal or not equal so
let's just stand this was returned then
use the ternary operator let's just say
and return if a B times a height is
equal to B times B then return true
actually that's just this so now we're
going to return the result of this
expression or this comparison here if
the area of the first way is equal to
the area of the second square obviously
just return return that comparison
result so now this method should work
let's test this out I'm going to create
another square here square 2 with a
width and height of 9 so we have two
different areas for these two squares
and then down here I'm gonna consult the
log the return value of this equals the
second method and actually call a static
method you call it directly on the
actual square class itself and not on a
square instance let's just start the
square here and then dot equals okay and
here we gonna pass in square number 1
and square
the two okay so now first to save this
and refresh the browser window in a
console we get false because here
clearly the area of a is different to
the area of B if I was to make the area
the same making both eight okay
so 64 here and 64 here for the area save
and refresh this one we get true so we
can see how we've used a static method
here now this static method doesn't
require an instance for it to work it
does in the regard of the actual
parameters but the actual method itself
doesn't ever say least got this or you
know this two area so there's never any
I guess referrals to the actual of this
keyword okay so there's no instance
bonded to this static method probably a
better example of this would be maybe a
safe method that will test whether or
not a width and height is a valid square
so for a square to be valid it needs to
have an equal width and an equal height
okay so let's just create a new static
method down here and call this one
something like is valid maybe is valid
dimensions okay
this takes in a width and a height so
now this this static method is
technically relevant to the square class
so we're checking if a square is valid
or a dimensions is valid based on the
width and height so if the width and
height are the same then it can be a
valid square let's just rich good yeah
let's just return the result of a
condition if you whip these people to
the heights then it is a valid sphere so
let's just return with equal to hot that
comparison result right there
so now down here again
the voltages console dot log iya consult
that log and then say once again
according these square class directly
and saying is valid dimensions and
passing in something like six and six
inside there if I was to save this and
refresh the browser we actually get true
okay because obviously six is equal to
six let me get that returnable over to
here supposed to make this seven and six
well we should get false in the console
refresh and we get false okay
so static methods I used for I guess
helper helper functions so they're still
relevant to the actual class but they
don't actually require an instance of
that class to work in fact if I was to
just get rid of these two guys right
here okay save and refresh we still get
the same result there's no error or
anything so you can see how it's sort of
like a helper function alright and
that's how you can use static methods in
classes in JavaScript
I talked about inheritance or the
extends keyword in regards to a
JavaScript classes so basically the
extends keyword allows you to achieve
the concept of inheritance in JavaScript
classes so you're basically going to use
this whenever you have a generic class
and then you want to actually create a
new child class of that generic one
while still maintaining its features and
behavior but a little bit extra so
basically it's when you have a parent
class to create a child class okay so
let's see how to actually do this so I'm
going to create a new class here and
this will be a representation of a
person so let's type out the class
keyword and then just say person and
just like that this person will have
let's just say two properties will have
them will have a name and an age so in
the constructor let's take in a name and
an age just like that and then assign to
instance properties we'll say this dot
name equal to the name and this stop age
equal to the age passed it okay this
will be our parent class the generic
class now let's just say inside our code
we have a function okay this function
will call this one something like a
develop software this function requires
a bunch of programmers to develop the
software so this are taking an array of
programmers just like that okay inside
here
basically we just say develop software
so each one of these programs are going
to develop some sort of software so as
you can see a normal person won't be
able to actually be passed into this
array because we expect program is not a
generic person with no attribute on
their skill or occupation so we're
actually going to create a child class
which inherits from this person
class and this child class is going to
be a programmer so we can achieve this
by creating a new class okay and call
this one programmer okay now if we tap
your extends here that extends and then
say person we've just achieved
inheritance so now we have a program
which extends a person which means it
takes in all the attributes and behavior
of this person so name an age and it
also will have its own custom behavior
and properties itself so I might just
create a new method inside the person
real quick and just say something like
just stripe or something like that so
describe this would just simply
console.log a message saying I am in
their name so I am I don't know dumb and
I am age years old okay say this name so
now this programmer class is going to
have access to not only these properties
but also access to the describe method
okay
so down here let's create the
constructor for this program we'll type
constructor here this for taking a name
and an H okay the same thing is the
actual parent class and also let's just
say years of experience will say here's
ease of experience so now inside here we
actually have to call the parent class
I'm sorry the parent constructor so we
still have to actually assign the name
and age but we can do this in a more
generic way by typing out super and then
passing in name and age so here this
super is basically just going to call
the constructor of the person that way
all this logic
still maintained in this class okay so
super name aid basically just calls this
in the parent class now down here is the
custom behavior of Vega of the
programmer let's just say this stop
years of experience is equal to the
depth parameter right there okay so now
before we define a new method for this
programmer let's just create some
instances of these people so down here
let's just create a new person so I'm
new generic person so let will say
person one sequel to a new person and
passing a name of something like Jeff
and an AIDS or something like 45 okay
let's also create a programmer will say
let's program one you could do a new
programmer passing a name such as I
don't know Dom myself age of 56 and use
of experience I've had about 12 okay not
really that's right so now we have these
these two people person we have one
person here another person we have two
people but the programmer is a special
type of person okay so we can now
console.log person one and do the same
thing for the programmer number one that
was to save this and refresh the web
browser in a console okay fair enough
let's just see what's happening yeah yep
cool put that perfect save them refresh
this one
oh we did a person name of Jeff age 45
programmer named on page 56 and a years
of experience 12 so we can see how we
have obviously this the same behavior as
the person with edit or sorry with them
with extra added functionality of 12
years of experience the prototype before
this programmer is person and you can
see how it all works
with the with the prototype chain and
the inheritance so you can see how this
programmer is a child of this person
class
okay so let's add some extra
functionality to this program alright so
down here let's just say develop
actually let's pull this method code
okay so make a new method here called
code and it'll just say okay console.log
and we'll say this dot name this dot
name is program oh he's he's coding
okay yeah so now obviously here only the
programmers have access to these methods
so false to say person one code it's not
gonna work let's save and refresh this
refresh uncaught type there are not a
function so a regular person cannot code
if I change this to programmer one this
time we get the message refresh we get
that right there so you can see how
we've added extra functionality to this
programmer class while still maintaining
the functionality of the bigger person
let's just prove this right now by
calling the describe method on the
programmer and not the person let's save
and refresh and we still get I've done
56 years old so you can see how
I'm maintaining the same behavior so
back to this function we might as well
finish it off so let's just create a new
Arabia get rid of all this stuff let's
make a new array call this one programs
equal to an array of programs
so we'll say new programmer say Dom with
five six years old and twelve years of
experience
one more let's just say Jeff once again
okay hey Jeff think it was 20 for some
like that and he's he's got four years
of experience okay
you might as well stop there that's fine
okay so now we can just obviously pass
in into this function here develop
software and pass in these programmers
inside the function body let's just loop
through all these programs so we'll say
for lips programmer in program
celebrities and we'll say programmer
okay so we're looping through what the
program is and just calling their code
method house to save this and refresh or
it gets okay cool
that's fine yeah
ah I think it's obvious enough get off
okay
give it up we fished this and we get
dumb is coding and Jeff is coding
alright and that's how you can achieve
inheritance using the extends keyword in
JavaScript
the concept of polymorphism in
JavaScript classes
so basically polymorphism is the act of
redefining a method inside a derived
child class of a parent so let's just
see with an example we'll go with the
typical animal example so let's just
define a new class inside here and call
this one animal which obviously
represents a generic type of animal okay
so for the actual constructor we're just
taking a single argument this would be
just the name of that animal okay and we
can set that to an instance property so
we can say this dot name is equal to the
name that is passed in in the
constructor alright so now we have an
animal with a name so let's just define
a new method inside here and let's call
this method make sound all right these
are taken out arguments now this method
right here is the one that we're going
to eventually override to achieve
polymorphism so let's just say for a
generic animal we're gonna consult our
log and we're gonna say generic animal
that sale okay so this is the make sound
method that is present in the parent
class of animal and it just says generic
animal sound so he falls to make a new
instance of this animal real quick down
here this is define a new constant and
call this one a 1 equal to a new animal
and we'll call this animal dumb
all right and then if I say a 1 dot make
a sound just like that we should now see
that in the console let's just save this
and refresh the web browser and we see
that right there ok so that's fine
now that's actually just
create a new child class of this animal
class and then override the make sound
method okay so let's go down here and
declare a new class let's call this
class doc okay so a dog is an animal so
let's just say dog extends animal all
right cool for the constructor let's
just take you in once again the name and
then called the super constructor
passing in name so that means just call
this constructor for the parent all
right so we have this functionality
right here now let's just redefine the
make sound method and this is called
polymorphism okay make sound this time
let's say console.log say woof okay so
we are now done so now supposed to make
a new animal down here or a new dog down
here new constant call this one a to
equal to a new dog let's call this dog a
[ __ ] now we're gonna call the make sound
method on the constant which is the type
of dog let's say a to dot make cell
phones to save this and refresh this
time we get woof-woof in the console you
can see how we're actually achieving
polymorphism here by overriding the
method inside the child class dog you
know of that in them in the parent class
makes sense so we're just basically
overriding it so false you comment that
out in the child class and save and
refresh we get once again the generic
sound so what's happening here is it's
actually checking on the dog class if it
has that method if it doesn't then it
checks the parent class and it uses that
one right there
all right so that's that's polymorphism
I'll just show one more example this
time calling these super inside the
actual overridden method so I can
actually call the parent method inside
the derives method so inside this makes
our method I can say super dot make
sound and that right there is gonna call
the parent class animal dot make sounds
so we'll actually see that message
followed by that message and this is
common practice you'll see how actually
using the generic behavior and then
adding on special functionality for the
special derived child class files to
save this and refresh the browser this
time we see here generic and then woofle
so these two right here are part of the
dog makes you add method call okay and
that's how you can achieve polymorphism
inside your JavaScript classes
I want to show you an example of how you
can use the JavaScript classes to make a
binding to a HTML elements so what I
mean by this is we're actually going to
be able to create a class which can then
manipulate the Dom or the document
object model directly so for example
here I have an unordered list element on
the HTML document with a few list items
inside it okay in the JavaScript I can
actually just type out lists and then
dot add and then add an item to that
list directly so for example list add a
bottle press ENTER and we say bottle
appears right there we can do the same
thing for removing an item let's say
list remove and pass in an index for
example index number one press ENTER and
is is removed okay so we're gonna make
this right here so inside the clean
document here we have a simple structure
so first let's just create the actual
unordered list item to use so let's say
ul with an ID of something like my list
okay so this list will be filled by a
Java Script so let's just say and put a
comment down say to be filled by jobs
okay so now we need to actually
reference this list on this list element
in JavaScript so using the actual ID
here we're going to make a new constant
with references of this unordered list
element so down here let's make a new
constant and pour this one something
like my list equal to document dot get
element by ID passing in my list right
there
so now my list means that element right
there
okay so now let's start by or let's
let's start creating the actual class so
let's make a new external failure make a
new file let's call this class list
bonding jeaious okay let's now link this
class in the actual HTML document plus a
script put a source of least binding
jeaious okay so in this class here let's
just actually firstly define this class
will say class
call this one list binding okay so in
this class we're actually going to be
able to pass in the my list element to
the class constructor okay so this class
will actually keep a reference to the
physical tag or element okay so in the
constructor let's just take in a single
argument and call this one element okay
now we can say this dot in list element
is equal to elements okay so we have an
instance an instance property here
called list element referring to the
physical list HTML element okay so now
we can make a underlying simple array
that will be filled with all that text
so we can say this dot txt list is equal
to an empty array so this text list here
might contain some strings for example D
code is not bad okay see back in the
actual demo we have we have that right
here so we can see how this array
structure
well eventually actually contain all
these text items right here that's what
the actual text list property is used
for okay so now let's just make a an
instance method for this class let's
call this method update say update so
taken no no arguments the update method
is actually just going to update the
physical Dom so the physical list
element with the items contained in text
list so you maintain an array of of
strings and then the update method is
actually going to insert all these
strings into the physical list element
yet property on this element so down
here we can start by first clearing the
the list element of list items so let's
just say remove all existing Ally
elements for stash tags okay we can say
while this stuff list element dot first
child so why there is a first child then
we can say this dot list element removed
child and pass in the first child so
this right here is gonna remove all the
existing Li tags from the list element
so let's just see an example of this in
use so back inside the HTML let's just
put some sample Li tags inside here will
say item number one and item number two
okay inside here let's make a new
constant okay called least by me this is
equal to a new instance of that list
binding class to say new list binding
taking in
my list okay so this is like a
registering this list element with this
list binding class okay
let's save this and refresh the browser
we get that about this
so now let's call the update method on
that list bonding and see what happens
just a list binding dot update and they
go away so you can see how that code
right here removes all the existing list
item tags so now we have to add add
let's stay fueled so feel ul / IL tag
Ally okay let's just am let's just fill
up this list element with all these
streams inside this text list array
property so let's just say for each of
the text list items so for each Potts
text of this text list
okay we're gonna say this dot list on
dot append child and we're gonna append
obviously a Li tag so how do we actually
convert a string to an li tag let's just
say this let's just say list binding dot
creates list item and passing tip so
we're going to make a static method
called create list item which will
generate an HTML element for for the
text that is passed it alright so let's
just make this static class or this am
the static method right now up here
let's say study for this one create list
item which takes in a single argument
being text okay for the body let's just
make a new constant here for this one Li
equal to document create element of an
allied tap okay then say Ally dot text
content let's put the actual text inside
the action tag and then the turn Ally so
now this method actually makes makes an
ally tap okay element elements slash tag
with text inside they actually pass in
right there alright
so now if we actually put some sample
data inside this array for example
decode and then bottle okay if I save
this and refresh the browser we still
get these two existing elements right if
we say list binding update now press
enter
they get replaced so here we are first
clearing the existing elements so we
clear them with that right there and
then add Li tags for each text or each
string inside this text list underlying
array right there okay let's make this
back to no elements okay
so now let's actually create the add and
remove methods we can first just get rid
of those sample tags save this all right
so let's make the add and remove methods
so basically these two methods right
here are simply just going to update the
underlying array that guy right there
and then call the update method so it's
going to be quite lean and what I call
it loose coupling alright so down here
let's make a new ad method alright
here's our taking some texts
we'll say text just like that inside
here let's just say this duck text list
and call the push a method we're going
to push text to the array so this will
add this text to this underlying array
quite simple and then we're gonna say
this up there so basically the add
method does it simple job adding the
actual text to the array then the update
method does its job of updating the
actual physical document object model
the actual HTML page alright let's just
save this and test their save them
refresh the browser
all right let's say a list binding dot
add all right let's add D code to the
list boom there we go let's add some
more for example bad dog so we works
completely fine alright good for the
extra remove method for a move add this
method right yeah
this will taking an index so remove an
item at a particular index index right
there okay then once again it'll follow
similar sort of structure it's gonna say
this got text list dot splice all right
that's an array method splice at the
index okay and then one so this means
remove an item starting at or multiple
items maybe starting at this index and
then how many so remove an item at this
index but only one of them okay so
actually removes one item please stop
update okay so similar thing modify the
existing underlying array and then
update the Dom right there let's save
this refresh my browser and yeah let's
add dog decoe and let's just say bottle
okay and then say list binding dot
remove at index one press enter
boom area all right so that's the whole
thing done but oh there's a recap what's
actually happening now right so what's
happening well in this class here
actually let's start with the extra HTML
so in the HTML we are making an
unordered list element right there which
is then passed into the JavaScript
through that method right there and then
we're making a new instance of the list
binding class passing in the actual
physical and ordered list element from
there in the class in the constructor we
are maintaining a reference to the
actual list element property and then
making an underlying array to store all
these strings of text to be displayed
inside the update method we are removing
all the existing list item elements and
then filling up the actual UL or the Oh
alt tag so this guy right here with the
actual text inside the underlying text
list array this is done by calling the
static method create list item which
simply just makes a list item element
putting the actual text inside that for
the add method we are simply just adding
adding a an item to the actual array and
then using the update method to actually
update the Dom once that has been added
so we're keeping things lean were only
actually updating what we need inside
the add method
sango's for the room method was removing
an item at that index and they want
again passing over to the actual update
method to do the actual dumb visual work
all right and that's how you can make a
binding from a JavaScript class to an
HTML element inside your JavaScript
classes thank you for watching and I'll
see you later